We are moving towards the end of part one.
Uh,
the first,
uh,
that is the 1605,
Quixote.
Uh,
and as we move towards the end,
uh,
you will notice,
I'm sure you will have noticed there are the,
there are a number of returns and repetitions,
uh,
which give a density to the fiction by being crossed referenced as it were
within itself.
Uh,
meaning that there are characters who reappear and,
uh,
incidents that are,
if not repeated exactly as before,
recall previous incidents.
There are three such character and or incidents,
uh,
one of which I will discuss,
in detail.
And two others that I will just mention briefly here at the beginning of today's
lecture.
These are the galleys slaves.
One to two is undress,
and three is the,
the post Prandial speech.
Now,
the Galley slaves,
uh,
are,
mentioned,
uh,
again,
when the priest and the barber bring up the incident to explain their presence
at the indoor or the presence,
uh,
in their,
meeting Don Quixote.
Uh,
they say that they were supposedly assaulted by these,
uh,
free,
prisoners,
uh,
as they were on their way,
not the person who has brought the,
uh,
Barbara and,
and presets as they were on their way,
uh,
to collect some money sent from America.
Uh,
they do this to embarrass the night and to persuade him that what he has done,
uh,
is not right.
That in fact,
uh,
it is a crime that the priest gives a proper legal interpretation to Don
Quixote's actions.
Uh,
he,
uh,
has committed a crime against the crown because the galleys leaves were under
its jurisdiction being that they were being sent to the galleys that they were
on the road and done.
They were being guarded,
uh,
by agents of the crown as opposed to other branches of,
of justice.
And,
uh,
remember that because of regional,
independence,
uh,
in Spain,
there were various kinds of,
uh,
of,
of police,
but,
uh,
these are the galley slaves were under the purview of the crown,
which makes Don Quixote's crime,
uh,
much more,
much the worst
these repairs.
The second mention of the incident of the freeing of the galleys lifts,
which is where Gnocchi hold these in fact nabbed by the Holy Brotherhood,
uh,
precisely for that crime.
Uh,
I will speak about this later,
but notice that the characters who are presumably out to bring don Quixote to
reason and go to bring him home,
go in and out of his madness,
uh,
participating and expanding it with their lies,
the participating and expanding with her lies his dilutions.
Notice that there is an elaborate lie here that the priest us come up with.
This is one of the larger themes of the Quixote that all those society cannot
cope with his madness because it shows the arbitrariness of laws from outside of
them.
Members of society are themselves towing a very thin line between their
compliance with societal laws and norms and acting insane,
insanely themselves.
Ultimately at,
and this may very well be beyond anything that's a rant,
is intended to do the figure of Don Quixote being a mad individual questions.
The very core of the rules and regulations that sustain daily life don't get
Hortense most or regional feature as a character of fiction is his being insane.
It gives them a transcendence,
the certain kind of trust sentence.
He is the truly the first insane protagonist in western literature and there
have been others since,
but none with this kind of transcendental form of a madness,
so that's the first of the returns
to undress
and the rest returns.
Remember that undressed was a young man that was being flogged by Huang.
I'll do though and don't be hope to intervenes and so forth.
I'm sure you remember this episode which took place during doggy hotels.
First Sally and the rest returns and reveals that would know Quixote did for him
made his situation worse.
This is parallel to the mention of the Galley slaves because it up that donkey
holders actions have had the opposite effect of what he intended.
In both cases,
he defends himself by saying that he was upholding the laws of chivalry,
which are superior to the laws and costumes of the time in which he lives.
But the interest in detail here,
the significant detail here is that I'm dressed is on his way to Seville,
which as we now know is the center of picaresque life.
It's a real,
it's a center of picker risk life and you will,
uh,
we'll have this reinforced when you read,
by the next class.
I hope the exemplary story ring kinetic and core Collegio which takes place
precisely in Seville.
So
the fact is that his return shows,
uh,
or suggests retrospectively that he was Picato all along,
that he was probably guilty when I'll do low flogged him.
So these returns cast light retrospectively on the previous previous episodes,
as I said,
they established this kind of inner world of references in the fiction Santo has
to give undressed something to get rid of him.
The appearance of characters,
uh,
they'll,
the reappearance of characters is a narrative device that Advantis we'll use
more frequently in part who,
which is a more tightly structured,
a novel and the return of characters is something.
Dot.
Some of set of Andis is,
uh,
followers in the 18th century,
like Henry fielding.
Uh,
we'll,
uh,
we'll use a,
if you have read,
if you remember your Tom Jones for instance,
the third reputation is the postprandial speech.
This is a word that I'm sure you will never forget after this class.
It is in Webster's dictionary,
so he's not a enrich.
Our share as it may sound to you
is opposed.
It's an after dinner speech.
Now,
this speech about arm,
this is the speech about arms and letters
this week about arms.
Our letters is the repetition or the near repetition of a similar previous
incident.
As I'm sure you have noticed,
the speech of the Golden Age,
that donkey halted delivered to the goat hurts right before the Marcella
Marcella episode.
Yeah.
This beach on arms and letters hearkens back to medieval debates like those wine
against water,
clerics against nights on so forth.
These were,
uh,
topics for rhetorical exercises like those four topics for a debate between
debating teams.
Nowadays it was a set topic,
arms against letters.
This is the reason why don't Quixote,
uh,
delivers the speech.
One of the reasons where he delivers his speech is part of his storehouse of
topics that he has in his mind.
But he's also true that Cervantes did practice both arms and letters and that he
valued both as did don Quixote himself.
That topic in the speech also,
uh,
refers to utopian models of behavior rose codafide by the renaissance.
Okay.
The courtyard the night,
the port or man of letters on in Spain,
the saint where models of department by Lazada I have rest than s out of his
name.
Belinda Sadek Castiglione,
uh,
who wrote a book,
you are getting progressively a list of important renaissance books that are,
that,
uh,
that you must keep in mind,
when reading as Advantis,
uh,
Castiglione [inaudible] is 1478,
1529 he published the book of the Courtier in 1528.
Okay.
It is a book in which these modes of behavior are codafide is ideal modes of
behavior.
Yeah.
The answer to that debate.
I mean,
the result of the debate is that the idea is don't get held his own idea,
uh,
of a reflective man of action,
which,
uh,
will,
then following will be personified in the captain who becomes the captive in the
next,
uh,
tail.
This is the current debate between the politically committed individual and the
intellectual in the ivory tower to establish a,
uh,
a clear cut distinction.
You know,
there are these debates about whether you want to be a checking him out or you
want to be a,
a great,
uh,
intellectual.
Uh,
so it's,
it has a sort of a contemporary relevancy,
uh,
but it is essentially a topic,
of the Times.
Um,
now again,
the folk was,
is on the intersection between literature and current history between fiction
and reality are medical Castro,
who's name I am going to mention several critics.
I don't have put their names here so that you know,
uh,
how to write it.
I Medical Castro.
Okay.
Road in a book called [inaudible].
Cervantes is thoughts or Toronto says a way of thinking through,
and this is ideas publishing 19,
25.
It's a book that I believe that I mentioned before,
but if I didn't,
it is the,
one of the best books are the most important books about Cervantes ever written
because in that book are Medical Castro dispelled the notion that set of
[inaudible] was as the phrase,
uh,
when,
um,
he may Henio level.
Okay.
You remember the word,
the wording Henio from one of the earlier classes with examined the hen yours.
Remember the book by Workday,
they sell one the doctor and remembering Henio isn't the title in Haniel.
So Hidalgo Don Quixote in Hanni your Lego.
That was,
that meant that Cervantes was an own learned that wit and natural that he's a
Toronto says,
uh,
Oh,
a hot innate ability as a great narrator and so forth.
He really lacked culture.
Uh,
this was a romantic idea.
The idea of,
of,
of the Creator who,
uh,
who,
who invents out of nothing,
uh,
his,
books and stories and all that.
Uh,
it was also a very nationalistic greeting or sort of lantus because those
critics say,
you know,
this was the,
this is the spirit of Spain expressing itself through Cervantes.
I want to go craft,
throw,
uh,
demonstrated that this was all hogwash.
Dot.
Cervantes was steeped in Italian Renaissance literature and thought and that
therefore he was no [inaudible] label at all.
Well,
in that book a medical culture rights,
I quote the debate between arms and letters is the harbinger of the importance
that learning and reason acquire over traditional life.
Being intellectual,
armed with theoretical reason is getting ready to intervene in the fate of
Europe unquote sort of that the intellectual,
uh,
arm with a theoretical reason is getting ready to intervene in the fate of
Europe.
In other words,
government will not be just left in the hands of kings and aristocrats who's in
ruling countries was based on traditional knowledge and practice passed down by
a tradition.
But the practice of government,
uh,
is becoming the object of serious and sustained reflection.
It is the birth of political science as a discipline that we are witnessing
witnessing in the 16th century.
And that it is reflected in donkey Hotez speech.
Uh,
in this regard.
The figure to keep in mind is Niccolo Machiavelli,
Niccolo Machiavelli 50 14,
69,
15,
27,
and his famous treaty school,
he'd bring cheaper the prince,
which was written in 15,
13 and published in 1532,
which is really the founding work of political science.
I know that you,
you may have a vague idea about Machiavelli mostly centered on the cliche that
the urns justify the means and so forth.
I'm sure you heard that and attributed as a machiavellian idea.
Uh,
but his book is much more than that.
It's very complicated,
complex and influential and important.
One of my Cavelli's models by the way,
was Ferdinand of Aragon,
whom you have met extensively while reading your Elliott
for a cunning ruler when you,
uh,
how to apply the rules of government Castro ads with regards to,
don't get notice.
Speech by the way,
got Troy is a very common last name.
He has nothing to do with the Castro cast room in,
in Latin meant a military encampment.
So therefore it was very easy for there to be many catheters in Spanish.
So that's why so many of them,
um,
gastro ads with regards to donkey hotels,
speech,
he says the following,
I want to quote a medico catheter again.
He says,
we are again faced with the essentially serve antionne dualism,
epic,
heroic fantasy versus reason and reflexive criticism at a point in his speech,
donkey heartaches claims.
But let us leave this aside because it is a labyrinth with no easy exit,
the fulcrum of Cervantes soul,
where both planes intersect.
Each other heroic fantasy and reasonable effort belongs to both those,
this theme dwells within him.
I'm still pulling a medical.
Castro dwells within Savantas being of a primarily formalistic neck nature,
but it is also the mold for the sociological preoccupations of the renaissance
or
however don Quixote does favor arms over letters as he says.
The fact is that he has just won the battle with the giant of which the speech
is a kind of celebration.
So he opt for arms,
uh,
over letters,
perhaps,
uh,
perhaps with Cervantes himself who always had a fondness for his life as a
soldier,
as you no doubt noticed in reading the tail of the captive.
So we get back to our speech,
um,
dinners topic.
This is the second again.
I said postprandial speech by Don Quixote.
The first was concerned with the golden age,
the Russian critic on Theoretician Mihail Bactine who won't have mentioned
before.
And I forgot to put his name,
but I'll put it again.
This is all of course an approximation.
There's name from the Russian.
Don't confuse him with this guy's Mikhail Bakhtin
in his book,
[inaudible]
gives a great deal of importance to dinners because his metaphor for the novel,
well,
what the novel is like,
Eh,
is the dialogue and dinners are essentially dialogic.
His,
uh,
there is a book on Bactine called the dialogic back teens dialogic imagination.
Now Francois [inaudible].
Oh,
I see.
Yeah.
Francois [inaudible] is yet another renaissance figure.
You must keep in mind he was French for a change,
not Italian,
and lived between 1494 and 1553.
He wrote this outrageous stories about Gargantua and punter grow cause you may
have heard about,
um,
then writes the following that I cannot resist quoting,
but Kim wrote a with a great deal of verb and,
uh,
about elements of popular culture that were incorporated into,
into literature.
He says,
I think he learned a lot from [inaudible].
So much so that he doesn't write about Cervantes because he may have been
redundant.
Eating and drinking are one of the most significant manifestations of the
grotesque body.
He's talking about the body,
the Gore Tex bodies of this,
of these characters in
the distant.
The distinctive character of this body is it's open on finished nature.
It's interaction with the world.
You can think of Saint Joe here,
these traits are most fully and concretely revealed in the act of eating.
The body transgressors here,
his own limits,
it swallows,
devours wrens the world apart is they're enriched and grows the world's expense
you encounter of man with the world which takes place inside the open,
uh,
counter don't know which takes place inside the open biking rending chewing
mouth.
I'm going to read that sentence again as we got and I got my mouth,
got a little,
uh,
the encounter of man with the world which takes place inside the open biting
rending jury mouth is one of the most ancient and most important objects of
human thought and imagery here.
Man.
Tastes the world,
introduces it into his body,
makes it part of himself.
Mine's awakening consciousness.
Could not,
but concentrate on this moment could not help.
Borrowing from it.
A number of substantial images determining its interrelation with the world man
counter with the world in the act of eating is joyful,
triumphant.
He triumphs over the world,
devours it without being devoured himself.
The limits between man and the world that erased two man's advantage on quote,
if you can see in all of this,
in all of the scenes of eating,
of which there will be many more in the,
in part to uh,
uh,
particularly sanctuary is involved,
in this,
uh,
joyful away.
Uh,
the barrier between me and reality is broken when I incorporate reality into
myself.
Make it a part of myself like eating it.
And this is what is celebrated in this Postprandial,
uh,
speeches.
Uh,
uh,
for Bactine dinners are the privilege,
location for dialogue,
dinner,
celebrate the end of work and the defeat of the world,
which is in fact consumed animals,
vegetables,
wine,
which is like the blood of the earth.
Wind loosens the tongs and the truth comes out on garden.
Remember that phrase,
the Latin phrase that I taught you before in we know ready us.
Why?
Uh,
Plato's symposium on,
I'm sure you have read,
uh,
and it's called really the banquet,
the last supper,
all mark ritual locations where the truth is to be spoken over food or after
food.
There are of course,
two other,
uh,
functions of the mouth that are not mentioned here.
Uh,
but the dual occasionally come into,
uh,
the erotic and the aggressive,
the erotic.
I don't have to,
and I won't go into here,
but it's too obvious.
Uh,
the aggressive of course,
uh,
the bite,
to spit.
And as we have seen in an earlier episode episode to vomit on somebody else as
we saw in the dialogue of vomit after the episode of the,
of the sheep.
So,
uh,
this is,
I am,
uh,
I am assuming you're back Tinian uh,
sort of,
uh,
persona as I make these comments because he was so interested in this,
in this bodily functions.
So the truth has prevailed in the resolution of all the conflicts and Don
Quixote celebrates,
uh,
with his speech and he,
the madman has been the vehicle of that resolution.
There's speech also serves as the transition to the captives tale in which,
uh,
which will be narrating episodes of war,
to corroborate a donkey halters ideas.
In fact,
uh,
the captive stale will narrate that battle called the battle of Lepanto who's
anniversary we are celebrating tomorrow.
The Battle of Lepanto occurred one October 7th,
1571.
So this is what I told you in the last year,
end of last lecture to ponder and see if you could come up with what anniversary
was being celebrated this week.
It is the battle of Lepanto.
This suggestion was that once the various conflicts were resolved,
donkey hotter,
celebrated by his speech on arms and letters through Bactine,
we concluded that this was a moment of truth,
ironically represented through the scene of the dinner.
There seems to be a whole tendency in the Quixote as we approach the end towards
the truth
that culminates in the story of the captive,
which is based on [inaudible] own life on episodes of recent Spanish history.
But more importantly,
episodes in which Cervantes was present.
Good.
Servantez circling back to himself,
be a part of this move towards the truth.
Is it a shift away from literary stories?
Uh,
do stories based on his own life?
And what does that mean?
As [inaudible] has said,
this is the second critic.
I am,
uh,
mentioning,
he's my friend.
He was my colleague at Cornell.
And of course,
Moron doesn't mean more on a,
as it does in a,
an English.
Uh,
so it is perfectly okay to have such a last name in Spanish,
although for poor said Yacko whom I love very much.
It's been retirement now in Spain.
It was the by the bane of his existence.
When professors,
when the students are Cornell,
said,
I'm going to morons class.
Uh,
but what could he do?
well he mostly went down by [inaudible] Adderall.
You,
I wrote,
you have means brook.
So some more.
In any case,
see the ACO model and I don't know you taste this event.
This has moved to create art with the truth to create art out of lived
experience.
Of course we might add here.
That's an event as a self,
as author has been presented as a sort of thin and biggers and shifting fiction,
uh,
and that would stand behind it are these snippets of autobiographical,
revelation,
a underlined by these self solutions like those two,
his pastoral romance lag Galatia in the scrutiny of the books episode and to
link Canadian Cortadito as donkey hotel leaves lives in.
This is the story of reading for next Thursday.
Everything is,
is,
is made to,
uh,
to,
to be coordinated in this course.
This a story of [inaudible],
which the innkeeper says is among the papers.
Somebody there left.
I wonder who that somebody would be,
uh,
will be included in the exemplary novels,
the book that you have,
and you will be reading that story for next Thursday.
So this is one of those snippets of,
uh,
Ellucian's to,
himself,
the real author of the keyhole.
So the,
the captive stale is the combination of the group of intertwined stories,
not the quite the last one,
but it is the combination of the,
uh,
group of intertwined stories.
Uh,
it is wining in which religious conversion incubates a synthesis of contraries.
That's our past is not just social barriers,
but even to sense the neoplatonic convergence,
typical of renaissance plot.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
I will unpack this in,
in other words,
this story entails not just an unequal marriage,
that is social inequality,
social,
uh,
clash,
but in marriage that crosses racial and religious boundaries.
So the union at the end,
it's not just the neoplatonic union of Renaissance,
uh,
ideas,
these union through love.
Uh,
but it is kind of,
uh,
I mean it's a more on a Muslim and risk.
Paris,
the Vietnamese a Spaniard and a Christian,
uh,
their,
their union is more trusting dental,
uh,
because it involves a union of these two,
religions.
Uh,
the Kale I maintained could be seen as the counterpart of 16th century Spanish
mystical poetry in which courtly love about which I've spoken at length here.
And petrarchan converge conventions are adapted to express religious fervor and
union,
not merely with the beloved but with God in Spanish.
Mystical poetry.
Uh,
the desire for union is not just with the beloved,
it is the desire for union with God.
I'm alluding here mostly to the poetry of Saint John of the cross,
1542,
15,
91 and mystic and one of the greatest parts of the golden age of any age.
The concluding a.
So what I'm saying is that this,
this,
uh,
capitis,
stale with is a fusion.
Uh,
these religious fusion is sort of akin to this mystic poetry in the Spain of a
16,
uh,
sanctuary.
And it is a combination of all these stories because it is much more trust and
dental what is going to be overcome.
It's much more transcendental
now.
That is a,
as you will see at the end,
they're concluding an unfinished story of one we that I a a who was a kind of
minor don't want and Leandra who's a bit of a fool,
uh,
and uh,
is unfinished because it's resolution would a convergence with the end of the
novel.
And uh,
of course the current event,
uh,
cannot have a,
an end because it is current and ongoing.
So that's why that story is left,
is left on finished.
But that is one that we will probably talk about in the next class because it
really very near the very end of the,
uh,
of the novel and I mentioning,
mentioning it,
uh,
she was so as not to leave any of these stories on my,
now the captives tail falls,
the traditional formula.
It has like a biblical residences.
The protocol song,
the father who sets his on off to life.
And remember here we learn,
uh,
we encounter that Iglesia Mar or reality,
a saying that I mentioned that the young man to go to the,
if you particularly if he doesn't,
it's not an aristocrat.
Uh,
he should be joined the church,
uh,
go out to seed so you get venture or join the retinue or the how of a great,
aristocrat or if possible,
the king.
Um,
this story illuminates retrospectively that of,
uh,
of Don Fernando.
It has provoked controversy among critics because of his religious,
uh,
background.
Uh,
Francisco Marquez Bigger Noya who was a professor at Harvard,
uh,
for many years and is also my,
he's retired now in Seville.
Um,
and uh,
who was also my friend,
but he was no friend of [inaudible].
You will see,
uh,
they were there,
debated over this,
uh,
story.
Uh,
mark and eny claims,
for instance,
according to [inaudible] dot.
Soraida a typically serve Antionne character like Marcella and Dorothea
exercises,
her desire for freedom within a religious context,
but is not motivated by religion per say,
religion.
I,
he becoming a Christian merely allows her to be free even at the expense of
bringing grief to her father.
Uh,
he,
apple,
uh,
which I,
I noticed that in your translation is conflated as a,
he bought apple.
It's the Spanish is he more out the
door?
Okay.
Monaro your claims on the contrary,
that the whole tale takes place within a very precise,
within very precise theological guidelines,
which she presents by quoting mostly from Saint Thomas Aquinas.
His point is that the issue of baptism is dealt with in a very strict
theological way.
So rather has not been baptized as the cup says because he has not been in
mortal danger and the baptism of adults in the Catholic church should take place
after they're learning about the faith except if faced by a life threatening
danger.
So if [inaudible] observes that this has been very closely followed in the,
in the book,
the same is true,
he maintains regarding songwriters use of her father's wealth and her leaving
him behind in grief conversion to the Christian faith justify doing violence to
nature.
That used to say to relatives,
he could quote,
I quote a CDR Comodo tomorrow your conversion to Christianity justified any
break with natural relations of kingship if this came into conflict with the
duty to convert that anyone who had learned of Christian doctrine had unquote
all the sounds plausible,
but it is hard to imagine surroundings as a theologian and wanting to mediate
between these two
span here
it is difficult to imagine is a this as a theologian and much less as a
scholastic theologian.
What is reflecting here?
I think it just simply the mores of the time,
uh,
which were of course are Catholic.
Um,
now modern Raju is much more persuasive,
persuasive.
It seems to me when he compares a hemo to Othello after the ladder first
threatens Soraida and later a later pleads with her in that very dramatic scene
when they leave him behind.
He says,
the scene in which all these develops is one of the great achievements of world
literature and the input of both to curse,
insult and also to cry and plead sort of antithesis has portrayed a man,
a real man.
I'm quoting,
uh,
meaning,
he's referring to a very scene,
the very dramatic scene as well,
the most dramatic scene in the whole of part one.
Okay.
Uh,
[inaudible] is also good when he says a court.
I agree with Spitzer's definition of servant Ian Perspectivism.
If you haven't gotten there,
you will.
You've got to,
you're the Spitzer piece,
which is I think the best and most important in my case book.
Um,
okay.
In terms of moral,
how morals,
however Cervantes is in no way a perspective is,
he says,
and in a node he adds [inaudible] perhaps we ought to point out here that
perspective is him,
is inherent in Christian thought prospective is him in the sense of a form of
modesty that recognizes the limits of old judgment and human knowledge is indeed
Christian humility and intelligence in its strictest sense,
the capacity to perceive the limit of our own creations.
Iuo Neha,
then he puts in the,
the word in the Greek,
the original word for Iraq or Iran.
But yeah.
Moraga ro,
you said his best when he points out,
referring to one critic goal.
Salus Lopez,
I find magnificent.
His observation that the marriage between the captive store,
either the new Christian is accepted by the audience of the [inaudible],
by the [inaudible] of the judge with no allusion to the impurity of blood that
could resolve from it.
And this is true,
once you convert to Christianity,
there is no impediment for them to marry and there is no stigma attached to
their issue.
Although of course there were in the span of the time a stigmas attached to
having more reach or Jewish,
uh,
a blog.
But here,
there is no inkling of it at all.
And he also,
he's also very good.
I think when he points out the Lingua Franca of Burberry is the most beautiful
expression of the efforts to communicate in that confused world.
The story of the captive demonstrates without any doubt that that primeval state
of communication in which human beings created language if there is none.
Algiers is an experiment with secular communication.
The renegade,
uh,
love and language are fundamental forms of expression,
meaning the renegade,
uh,
on all of these characters speak these mangrove,
quote unquote language made up of all of the languages.
And that,
uh,
he says it's an a form over the expression of this human,
overcoming,
of,
uh,
of linguistic barriers by,
by,
uh,
me,
but because of their love and their desire to communicate with each other.
I,
in terms of the cavities,
I would emphasize,
I would emphasize that.
So [inaudible] is a woman of action that she is indeed very much like Dota.
I mean,
she's the one who work,
orchestrates their whole thing,
who gets the money for the escape and so forth.
She's not doterra who chooses her destiny in,
in her are a combined the figures of the renegade and the saint and the
seductress and a hemo.
Datto is perhaps the most dramatic and well rounded secondary character of part
one.
Uh,
he's this pair and losing his daughter,
his plea to her vowing to accept her and his bowing to et Cetera back in her own
terms is full of pastors and of tragic death.
In this,
I agree with [inaudible] and underline the fact that this is a very important
character in park one.
Perhaps,
as I said,
the most important second character,
the most dramatic perhaps of the whole book parts one and two included.
Now we moved to a
very strange episode.
I want to move to a very strange episode,
dokey.
How the hanging from the window,
uh,
that it is a very strange episode for which I have,
an explanation of sorts.
I have never been able to explain to myself,
uh,
this episode,
which is of course,
I mean Marty [inaudible] and the innkeepers,
uh,
daughter having fun at the expense of a,
of donkey holder.
Remember that don't get how they have been aroused by the innkeepers daughter
and that he had actually grab Marie tonyism,
pulled her into bed baths,
Marilyn Hall and all of that.
So they are in a sense,
uh,
are getting back at him here in this,
rather cruel with this rather cruel joke of having him hanging from,
uh,
from the window.
This seems to be a distorted version,
a perversion of the part of Mary Therese and incubators,
daughter's daughter of scenes in the cavities tail as if every important episode
had to be projected in a different register.
Follow me in this if you will.
I don't have to persuade you at the bank knew or remember most of the call the
area where the captives are kept.
The captain,
he sees a hand through a window.
Remember he sees the hand sort.
I that turns out.
Um,
um,
there is an exchange of messages with that hand through that high window,
the window in the Henry up here in this episode,
the relationship was no connection to the a in the action in the plot.
It is to simply a remembered image to me is like a symphonic Motif motif
repeated and expanded upon in a different key.
I don't know if I can convince you of this,
but it's the only way that I can,
uh,
explain this episode that there are echoes and remembrances of this window on
this hand and all that they appear here.
And again,
it's like a musical motif in us in a,
in a,
in a symphony that is repeated.
Otherwise,
it's simply another act of cruelty against don't,
Quixote of which are quite a few,
uh,
throughout,
the book.
And,
uh,
you can make all kinds of symbolic and allegorical readings of it that he's
hanging from the window and use feed.
I just barely touching the ground.
It can't quite touch it.
And I,
and in a way you could say that that is Don Quixote's,
uh,
state in the world that he's in me.
They're just barely touching,
uh,
the,
the ground with his feet and all of that as possible.
Uh,
but I proposed this reading of it,
uh,
as bizarre as it may be an interpretation.
Now,
I said at the end of my last lecture,
uh,
and I repeat it today,
that we are coming to the end of part one.
Don't forget that Cervantes had no idea at this point that he would write a part
two.
So this would be the conclusion of the novel that he began to write.
Probably as we saw,
he began to write the novel,
uh,
after donkey hotels,
second Sally after the scrutiny of the books and he's having engaged Santiago at
his squire
because the two parts are bound together.
You may not have the sense that you're coming to an end because you have another
big chunk of book to read,
but this is the end of part one that we are coming to.
And it was the end of the novels around run this set out to write or be wound up
writing.
Now the sense of endings in fiction is crucial.
As Frank Kermode established in his wonderful book,
the sense of an ending that I recommend to everyone,
Frank Kermode,
e serve Frank Kermode by now
the ending inviters to read retrospectively into the story that precedes it and
suggest an author's conception of history and of the loop of life as it were,
as his characters meet benign or violent deaths as conflicts are resolved and as
a feeling of completion is felt by the reader in Aristotle's poetics about which
we'll be talking soon.
When we meet the Canon of Toledo,
it's,
Eh,
the poetics established how parks should be ordered,
linking beginnings with ends and bolts with Middles Cervantes had that in mind,
but also the endings of chivalric romances and picaresque novels in which
deployed essentially followed the development of the hero's life,
uh,
from birth to death to death or,
to the point at which the bigger we'll began to write,
which involve the death and resurrection,
you know,
a conversion.
But the Quixote is neither,
uh,
in fact,
it will,
it is not actually very dramatic.
It's not a picaresque,
it was totally new.
At best it could be said,
and I repeat this,
that it is the parody of which evaluate romance,
hence deliberately as we deliberately distorted version of it.
As such,
it is a kind of Metta to evaluate romance that you've all read romance about
you.
I'll can romances so ending it will be no easy matter for Savantas as we shall
see at least two strands of the plot.
Uh,
two stories within,
within the,
uh,
two strands of the plot,
are closed in episodes,
uh,
at one Palo Meccas in,
this is done by appealing to the judicial or legal casts of the novel.
We just,
as we have seen involves the perpetration of crimes,
has ms and misdemeanors by the protagonist band and by the implied or actual
presence of representatives of the state,
in this case,
the crown.
So the first sort of conclusion or conclusions that we have here have to do with
rest solutions,
restorations,
and the capture and arrest of Don Quixote.
I pause here to explain why this turn to the legal,
which I have explained in further detail in my book called law and the law
instead of antis published by Yale press on which is in your bibliography and of
which I'll give you a very brief synopsis here so that you can understand why I
read these endings and the endings of these episodes in this fashion.
I have maintained in that book,
uh,
that the picaresque and hence Samantha's is Nawbo reflects the importance of the
elaboration of a dense and complicated legal system in 16th century Spain.
You may have observed some of this while reading Eliot,
this increase was part in due to the development of the printing press,
which made the issuance and dissemination of laws much easier and also the
development of a modern state organized as a bureaucracy to administer the
precariously United peninsula and his vast overseas and pyre.
Okay.
If you have read Eliot,
you understand that Spain's was a modern state in the make.
Normally Americans have a sense of Spain or some as backward,
but no,
Spain here was at the forefront of history.
This situation brought about the creation and maintenance of state archives in
which myriads of cases both criminal and civil work kept on classified.
The distinction,
criminal and civil was not quite established a search,
although in practice it was a criminal case is a criminal act is,
is against the state.
In this case against the crown.
A civil crime is committed against somebody else.
Another person.
So,
uh,
the archive was a form of state control containing many stories from which the
picaresque novel derived or drew it's cases like the one involved in la,
sorry,
Joe and Guzman.
[inaudible].
Your story is like a deposition given to a judge to justify his present
predicament.
He is the husband of an arch priests,
ministers legal discourse made possible the minute description of the real as
opposed to renaissance.
John was like the pastoral which gave an ideal,
uh,
description of the world.
Legal discourse is in my theory,
the foundation of the novel and narrative that deals in the beginning,
mostly with criminals like [inaudible] and continues to deal with criminals.
And that describes a,
as only legal documents can describe,
uh,
the business of everyday life.
The intertwined stories of part one involving legal issues,
mostly focusing on testamentary law,
read like cases taken out of those archives,
not so then oval of the curious in pattern isn't pertinent.
That is obviously drawn from renaissance literature in his protagonist who is a
fugitive from justice,
an outlaw set of antisense created the first important novelistic protagonists
drawn from the archive as it were.
His is the case of the insane.
He go who set out to act out chivalric fantasies and in the process committed a
series of crimes.
He is the first,
okay
hero fugitive from justice in the western tradition
in the process,
Atlanta's uses settings like the desk poblano that I have explained here.
A drone from Spanish law and in the Holy Brotherhood has drawn into the fiction,
the police of the times,
the depiction of a real world for say,
Advantis involved at world health together precariously by the law and whose
representation could not be accomplished without recourse to legal language and
concepts.
All of the situations and the Quixote are framed within legal discourse.
This is the reason why endings begin with resolutions,
restorations on the capture of don't haughty to get back to uh,
these endings that I'm going to now describe and analyze his partial endings.
The episodes at the end,
towards the end of part one are the climax of the,
of the first Quixote.
Don't get hold.
This defeat of Panda Filando is the culmination of his adventures.
He's most resounding feet,
these adventurous where all the humor and in spite of donkey halters ridiculous
behavior I successful in bringing about peace.
Dorothea admits as much donkey Holtec is not an angelic Beatrice whom the
pilgrim meets in the divine comedy towards the end of Purgatorio as he read it,
read is to enter Paradiso neuron epic hero like an els who winds up founding
Rome.
But he does bring about peace and justice in the world that it has been his lot
to be thrown into.
This is,
as I have said earlier,
part of the overall irony of the book does such a preposterous figure is the
agent of providence through his intervention.
Don't,
Fernando agrees to marry Doterra and make good on the promise that he made her
the night he stolen to her room and the flowered her swearing to become her
husband.
Uh,
Lucinda is returned to Cardinia who had been wrong both by her and by Don
Fernando crossed the marriage vows,
bringing this conflicts to a hoppy comedy like ending,
but such elevated kind of justice is not the only kind of finale that takes
place at the end.
Resolution also takes place at a legal level in the most concrete and my newt
fashion as restitution is made to those who have suffered injuries or damages
and are owed money as a result,
don't Fernando on the priest compensate the second barber and the innkeeper who
had been complaining about all the destruction and whose business not to mention
the consumption by the night and his choir and their mouths.
The second barber had had his base in stolen and dented and his donkey and he
drank.
His harness had been stolen.
Financial institutions such as these are a form of closure drawn from the law.
It is what making whole make means.
In current legal terminology.
An individual is brought back to the state,
he or she was in the damage occurred.
Restitution is the ending to a story that began with harm and the decrease of
one's property or wealth.
Okay.
Gnocchi Quixote for his parties.
Finally apprehended by the Holy Brotherhood.
This part,
this is part of the all encompassing closure of the novels plot don't get
healthy on sun.
Joe had been pursued by the holy brotherhood with an order of arrest for the
night because of his having freed the galley slaves.
A sanctuary had feared all alone.
They had committed other crimes such as killing sheep,
breaking a man's leg,
and stealing property from him and his companions.
The trooper reads the arrest order,
the description,
uh,
comparing the description in it,
in the address,
in the arrest order.
We donkey holders features in one of the most hilarious reading scenes in the
book.
Okay,
I'm reading from pages four Oh eight four oh nine of your translation and I hope
you have read these before and laughed as much as I do every time I read it.
But one of them,
the true person,
namely he who had been kicked and mold by Don Fernando be thought himself that
among some warrants and see how to about him for apprehending certain
delinquents.
He had one against Don Quixote whom the holy brotherhood had ordered to be taken
into custody for setting up liberty.
The Galley slaves or sanction had very justly feared.
Having this in his head,
he had in mind to be satisfied with or the person of donkey Hopi answered to the
description and pulling a parchment out of his bosom.
He presently found that he looked what he looked for and setting himself to read
leisurely four who was not a great reader at every word he read.
He fixed his eyes on Gnocchi haughty and then went on comparing the marks in his
warned with the lines on Nokia of them of Don Quixote's physionomy and found
that without any doubt,
you must be the person there in described.
And as soon as you have satisfied himself rolling off the parchment and holding
the war on his left hand,
we just right.
He laid so fast the whole of funky hotel by the color that he did not suffer him
to draw breath,
crying out loud,
helped a holy brotherhood and that everybody may see I required in earnest a
earnest,
read this word wherein it is expressly commanded to apprehend this highway
rubber unquote highway rubber.
That's what Hudson guild that is described and in fact literally he is.
Why is it hilarious?
Because the law should be the ultimate and most reliable institution in the rep,
in the representation of social reality,
particularly of individuals in trusted with upholding it.
Yet it's agent is a kind of dolt who can barely read because that beyond that,
because the interpretation of the real is always problematic and difficult as
he's reading itself and hear,
those are my noodly reenacted by the trooper.
This is express brilliantly,
but the trooper looking at each feature of donkey hotels after reading it in
this world,
and I'm comparing it with the night
like Velazquez checking to see that what he's painting corresponds to his models
in Las Meninas is a very same uh huh.
The very say moment.
Here we have a fori ds agent experiencing difficulty establishing who a person
is on with writing experiences,
with writing the very vehicle through which the new legislation establishes his
power over individuals.
One can only imagine how Don Quixote's description was obtained from the guards
from whom he freed the galleys leaves,
taking down notes as they spoke.
That is a whole take on the trials of representation dramatize in this very,
very comical scene.
So as you can see,
uh,
all of these,
restitutions,
uh,
horror po are part of the closure of the book that belonged to the legal costs
of,
uh,
of the novel.
But the most important in that league within the legal cast is the apprehension
of donkey Quixote himself by the holy a brotherhood.
This is sort of loops the plot.
It was the brewer.
But now we will have to,
uh,
to see how a UN speak about the terrain organized to cage Don Quixote and bring
him back home.
But we will do that in the next class.